Do I have to take the medication several hours away from using the rife?
So if a person is using a rife machine, is that going to interfere with the medication they're using?
Is what this person's asking?
The answer's no.
And the rife does not interfere with any medication, any supplements does not interfere with
anything else you're doing. So it's using light frequencies, and there's no contact or indications of
using the rife while you're doing anything else.
You could even use other therapies while you're doing the rife.
You could use a rife if you have an electrical implanted device like a pacemaker.
There's no contraindications to using a rife.